You are listening to radio lab radio lab
from [inaudible], W.N.Y.S. T. E
n NPR Three two one. Hey, I'm Jad
Abumrad. I remember quill week.
This is radio lab podcast
and today on the podcast, um,
well first we've got a story from
our, uh, old producer of Lula Miller.
She's not old. She's just has been
with us and now is it in school right?
Is that she's actually kind of young
chronologically. She's not old.
She's old to us. Yeah, it's
an old soul. Uh, any case,
this is a story about some of the sticky
issues that result when you try and
empathize with another being. Yeah,
it's a very different story
than one we've ever told a,
it started for Lulu when
she spoke with them. We'll,
she'll handle the introductions.
Can you introduce yourself?
A award winning author, fantastic husband.
Any nine out of the year or the
year? No, I'm Jeff Lockwood.
I'm a professor at the University
of Wyoming is an entomologist.
You mean like a bug guy? The bug guy.
And mostly he studies
crickets and grasshoppers.
And this story involves a kind of
crickets. That's well different,
the gorillas. Yeah. The grill accrediteds
yeah. And are they related to Katy?
Did you think of a griller?
Credit is like a cricket
on steroids. Okay.
Sort of like the whole Cogan
of crickets. First of all,
he says they're a little bulkier
than your average cricket.
And they tend to have very strong jaws,
very strong jaws and mandibles
that are really sharp,
sort of like a serrated knife.
And most of all, they're vicious.
They all had to be caged separately.
If you put them together, they would,
they would fight to the death. Yeah. Wow.
And so when I would go in in the mornings
and reach into one of their cages,
as soon as they saw him coming,
they'd fly into this rage.
It's really sort of a show stopper.
They'll sort of rear up on their hind
leg, feet, their abdomens on the ground,
layer out their wings, and then
clamp onto his fingers. They would draw
blood. Whoa. Wow. So I use this, uh,
this glass probe on,
on, on the big boy, uh,
at least until the point at which he
snapped off the end of the glass rod.
Holy Moly. So I ended up with, with the,
actually there are two
that were very large. Um,
I would just take their cage when I,
when I went in and pop it
in the refrigerator and
go get a cup of coffee and
within 15 minutes, because
in sex or cold blooded,
they would be anesthetized by the
cold and I could lift them out.
That's cheating. That was my solution
for them. The little guys I could manage,
the big ones, I'm a little bit of
chill in the morning is all it took
to the point is these creatures
were completely alien to him.
There's like nothing about
them he can relate to,
but over time, the more he studied them,
the more he started noticing things
that made them seem way less foreign.
See, I kept these in these, for example,
as soon as he'd put one into a new cage,
it would make itself a little nest.
And once it has that little nest built
that's home in a very real way because by
moving them around to different cages,
he soon realized that they could
differentiate their, their nests.
They can actually tell the difference
between their nest and another.
And how do they do that?
They secrete a pheromone chemical and
each cricket is able to self identify its
own odor. Whoa. It gave me the sense,
and I think there's something to this
that they had a kind of capacity to
recognize self. Oh interesting.
We don't see that much in insects,
but they had a what appears to be
a capacity to say this is mine.
And then he began to think
differently about that crazy rage too.
Cause if, if you think about
it, here's this creature,
it's completely vulnerable to attack.
They really don't have a very
good defense for themselves.
They don't excrete nasty chemicals,
they don't stain, they can't fly.
So it's not going to
go flying away either.
So maybe that rage is their only strategy,
which again drew me into
thinking that I understood them.
Perhaps these little guys were more like
me than than many other insects that I
had worked with. So he
grew to really like them.
But then one day I'd been working
with this particular griller,
accredited China, move him
from one cage to another,
and he was agitated and had
decided to go on the offensive,
which involved trying
to come out of the cage.
So he was scrambling up the side of the
cage and to keep him from getting out,
Jeff slammed the lid down as he was just
at the edge and caught him between the
lid and the edge of the cage.
And I, you know,
quickly lifted the lid up and he fell
back into the cage and I looked down at
him and, uh, what had happened
was I had ruptured his abdomen,
a split right down his
belly shapes and [inaudible]
some of the, um, the Viscera, um, and,
and kind of Glob you have of
yellow fat was leaking out.
Yeah.
Who was he and out of his
body? I, I felt guilt.
And then of course, I
felt sorry for an animal,
but what really struck
me was what he did next,
which was curl his head
downward, uh, toward his abdomen,
pause for a moment,
and then began consuming his own innards,
consuming the viscera that, that
had, that was oozing out of his body.
Um, and so he was, he was
literally cannibalizing himself.
Wow. That is disgusting.
It was horrifying. Mine.
Um, I had sort of like, I'd come to, I had
come to know them. Yeah. And then this,
this was just so out of the
imaginable, but the instant,
that word popped into
his mind. Unimaginable.
He had this sort of Pavlovian
reflex and he thought of this guy,
an old professor of
his, Dr Lefarge lefarge.
He was one of my mentors at
Louisiana State University.
You said this is a teacher
of his, Yep. Insect behavior.
He was one of the younger faculty
members when I was there, mid thirties,
slight of build, but incredibly intense.
He's kind of an expert in animal violence.
And the thing he harped on over and over,
the thing he was trying to pound
into their brains was objectivity.
Two separate ones,
the emotions and interests from
the object of study and uh, yeah,
these wire rim glasses. And I,
and I remember if, uh, if, uh,
if you would ask you a question
like why does the gorilla created,
do it's crazy war dance and you tried
sort of reading in will intention mental
states maybe cause it's angry or scared,
you would just drop his Chin and
look over the top and tear you apart.
His job in the classroom was to make
us good objective observers and Jeff,
Jeff stayed in touch
with him over the years.
I wanted to be good at this as
he set up his own lab. You know,
I had a stake in, in,
in earning his respect.
And so that day as he's watching the
gorilla created consume its own guts
thinking, okay, what would
lefarge see in this? So Mike,
my sense in my research is that what this
gorilla credit had done was perhaps to
have detected the odor of its own fats.
It sort of drew the conclusion that this
must be something good to eat without
sort of grasping that it
was, it's its own self,
the smell of its own fat triggered a
feeding behavior that that's highly
adaptive. Um, you know,
to feed on fat fats are very hard
to get hold of out in the world.
And so when you smell fats,
it's, you know, it's, you know,
it's like us and donuts, right? Um,
yeah. Go for it. Triggers feeding. Yeah.
It triggers feeding. So clearly these
things don't quite have a sense of self.
Right. So, so maybe they're not just like
me, which is always lefarge is point.
Don't put the creature in your
box. It doesn't want to be there.
It's sort of a moral danger almost to
sort of not allow the organism to be what
it is.
It's almost a sort of possess it or to
own it and to really treat the insects
sort of with a, with a, with,
with a deep respect, right.
Is oddly enough to treat them objectively.
[inaudible],
you know, he, he was one of the,
one of the professors who actually
engendered a kind of a good fear
[inaudible]
and he was the kind of person who
you, um, who you wanted to please
[inaudible].
Is that better? A little louder.
Yeah, a tiny bit. Is that okay?
Oh, that's great. Great,
great. But then years later,
something happened that challenged
Jeff's ability to do this,
to be the kind of scientist
that lefarge wanted him to be.
We're recording over here and there's
really only one person who can tell us
this part of the story. Will you,
um, introduce yourself? Okay.
My name is Tamara Carboni. Tamra
is actually not a scientist.
She worked for the Louisiana
State Museum and back in 1989,
she and Dr Lafarge, whose
first name is also Jeff,
we're working together
on this termite problem.
The termites were getting really bad in
the French quarter and it was her job to
preserve the historic homes. And
Jeff was studying the termites.
I never imagined that I would
be fascinated by termites,
but I was so, he made it fascinating.
Yeah. Fascinating. But then
one night in July, July 25th,
they met for dinner to talk about
how the project was going. And, um,
we were walking home, well,
he was walking me to my house around 10,
10 30 at night and I think it must have
been raining or there was a threat of
rain because Jeff was carrying an umbrella
and I could hear footsteps behind us,
very determined sounding
footsteps. And, um,
we got to a corner across from my house.
And at that point,
this person came around us
in front of us and he said,
close your eyes. And in the process
of closing my eyes, I saw the gun.
[inaudible]
so she closed her eyes in a second later,
she felt a tug on her purse.
I could feel him take hold of the
straps and I was not going to resist.
And as I felt him do that,
I could hear Jeff say,
don't do that. At that instant,
I don't remember the
shot at all. You know, I,
I felt Jeff move and I guess
at that point I opened my eyes.
This guy had already
run, never took my purse.
I saw Jeff running toward my
house and I just ran after him.
I had no idea he was shot,
but he got onto the porch and he collapsed
on his back.
And at that point he was gushing blood
[inaudible]
and I was trying to get Jeff to
understand that help was coming and I kept
saying, um, you're going to
be okay. They're on their way.
And did he say anything? He couldn't talk.
He just, he had this kind of stare
and I just watched him die.
Mm.
The news came, I a phone call
and it just seemed, you know,
it was just kind of one of those,
those classic, unreal moments.
Something about this,
you know, must be wrong.
It wasn't Dr Loofah or
she wasn't really killed.
It seemed particularly hard to grasp.
On one minute I'm with this vital
person and the next minute he's dead.
Sadness, anguish, confusion,
hysterical, crying.
I was in shock. They never
found his killer. Never
found out anything about him,
who he was, why he would do this,
just this seemingly senseless act.
And that's how Jeff understood it
for years, that it was senseless.
But over time, something
odd started to happen.
The fudge started appearing in his brain
telling him that that word wasn't good
enough and he began to ask himself again,
how would Dr Lefarge want
me to think about this?
How would he think about his own death?
Okay, so I wonder if, if you
do have the essay with you. Um,
so he writes an essay, we read
the last four paragraphs of,
of the essay will one, two, three, four.
The year after I left Louisiana and
came to Wyoming as a freshly minted phd.
The first thing he does is he takes
lefarge his attitude on violence.
Violence is the baseline strategy
for most encounters between,
and indeed within species. It's
not some evil outlying thing,
but instead a baseline
strategy for all animals.
And in that light,
he looks at the actions of that night
sort of dispassionately. For most humans.
First he figures this kid was probably
mugging them because he was poor,
hopeless, poor, angry in her scared.
The woman became tangled
in the strap doctor,
the fudge having his own instinctual
reaction stepped between them.
So don't hurt her. You can have the
purse. I can picture him doing this,
but perhaps that action
itself scared the kid.
The young man drew a gun
and fired point blank.
I showed the essay to Tamra. Yeah,
well, no, that's not, I mean,
I don't think, and I don't know if he
stepped forward or not. You know, again,
my eyes were closed. I could
feel some kind of movement.
I certainly don't think
he stepped between eight.
There wasn't much space
to step between us.
For Tamra has been over the
event a million times in
her head and doesn't add up
so easily. First of all, when
Dr Lefarge spoke to the kid,
it wasn't exactly a command. It was
more like tunc to that and he was like,
don't be an idiot. Don't do that.
It wasn't really threatening.
It was more like, look,
logically, let's not do this.
And while she gets that,
the kid might've been scared
and not been intending to shoot.
If he never ever could imagine
himself shooting somebody,
he wouldn't have had a loaded gun.
I can't relate to this person.
I can't imagine doing violence to
another human being or killing them.
Um, I can't relate to that
at all. And over the years,
her friends and family coworkers tried
all different kinds of ways to help her
make sense of it. Nothing really helped.
But there was someone that I
worked with, my boss actually,
who had been in Vietnam and
he took me aside and he said,
you know, you'll never understand this.
You're not going to understand
it. Yeah. Like don't even try.
I don't think there's any sense to be
made out of it. If we just stopped there,
then it's to say that,
that it's somehow um,
unnatural or inhuman and in
fact in a weird kind of way,
it's profoundly human. There's
no way I can understand it. Yeah.
In the end,
the essay itself kind of falls short
and Jeff admits that it just isn't
sufficient. But he says there is
a way of understanding this event.
He just hasn't gotten there
yet. But it is out there. Yeah.
It has to be. And Dr Lefarge would
have, I think said this as well.
[inaudible]
but for the moment, yeah.
I think I can say that
I, I understand, uh,
another beans eating its own
leaking and trials, um, at a,
at a level that I can't
understand. One of my fellow beans,
um, you know, pulling the trigger and, uh,
[inaudible] him killing
the man that I love. Yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] I am
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks to Lulu Miller
and to Jeff Lockwood,
his original essay first
appeared in Orion magazine.
It's called the nature of violence.
Definitely worth the read. Yes. See,
I am of the school that says that you
can't really make sense of violence like
that.
This is just a hint of
the danger of living in,
in a profoundly disordered
world, which looks,
I think I'm moved to school though,
that you have to try to make sense,
even if there's no sense to be made. Yeah.